it's almost inconceivable to people
today that only sixty years ago this
country had states in which African
Americans African American children
could not attend schools or other public
places in striking down official
segregation the Supreme Court did a
magnificent thing unnecessary but it
also did something much more it said
that we have ideals in this country
they're enshrined in the Constitution
but they go beyond what the Constitution
itself commands Constitution only
reaches state action so all private
action in the country is beyond the
control of the Constitution so Brown
spoke not only to state action but it
said as a country the Fourteenth
Amendment the Bill of Rights embody
embrace values that we all really share
in our lives generally so it was about
integration it was about overcoming
racism it was about trying to make a
society that is just especially given
its past
so for the next generation the country
struggled very actively with both the
explicit holding and with the more
general symbolic holding of brown and
with great success I mean I think you
know the country is a far better place
than it was in 1953 before Brown versus
Board of Education during this
generation right after Brown
universities all across the country
essentially said we have to do our part
to try to help with giving access to
African Americans and also Hispanics and
Native Americans we have to do more to
give access to these people who have
suffered generations of discrimination
and and unfair treatment and we would
benefit we would all benefit from a much
more embracing society and so
universities again almost unanimously
all across the country began doing what
they had been doing and continued to do
in a variety of other ways that is build
student bodies that are diverse
so universities have for centuries said
we want people from different parts of
the country we want people from
different parts of the world because
it's very important that young people
come together and study and be educated
in an environment where there are people
about whom they may have stereotypes or
they may not know them and they they
need to get to know the different kinds
of people that are in the world
so they embraced affirmative action and
by calling it that it seemed to
distinguish it from other things that it
was doing but it was more of the same
but embracing of african-americans
Hispanics and Native Americans this was
challenged at the end of the 1970s as
unconstitutional some qualifications
were made in a case called Bakke a
decisive opinion by Justice Lewis Powell
laid out the rationale for why colleges
and universities could do this and the
emphasis he put was on educational
benefits of having a diverse student
body and he importantly said you cannot
do this because there's been past
discrimination and you as a university
need to rectify a remedy that you can't
do that
this continued as the sub state of
affairs and then as groups opposing
affirmative action began to become much
more aggressive in the late 1980s and
90s the issue was joined is this really
constitutional to for universities and
colleges to engage in affirmative action
since the mid 90s I would say this has
been a hotly debated question in America
and it's been debated primarily through
the courts some of the major case of
course which I was involved in is Gruder
and that was decided by the Supreme
Court in 2003 and a great victory though
five to four so narrow but it was a
great victory for colleges and
universities to continue building
diverse student bodies more recently
that challenges have continued and one
of the ways in which opponents of
affirmative action have responded to
Gruder is by trying to get ballot
initiatives to amend their constitutions
and within states to prohibit
affirmative action just recently the
Supreme Court narrowly again upheld that
kind of a tactic there are now ten
states in the United States that
effectively bar affirmative action in
public universities within their states
that's where things stand
Brown is more than simply integrating
some schools in the south it was about
America and its ideals
and much has been done we are
justifiably proud as a society and the
integration that has followed but any
sensible observant person would have to
say there is a lot to be done if you
look at recent data about the situation
in K through 12 public school education
it is shocking how much segregation
remains in the United States recent
pieces on the reefs aggregation of the
American South point up some school
districts more segregated today than
even before Brown we're talking about
large percentages of young African
American children who attend all-black
schools at this point and many many
American children who are white are in
schools that are all white and therefore
the goal of an integrated society does
not begin it is still significantly
present in K through 12 public schools
all across the country not only in the
South but New York State recently has
been identified as the most segregated
school system in the United States and
we're talking 50 60 plus percent of
African American children who attend
basically all-black schools
so we have a issue in the society how
are we going to continue how are we
going to continue with the work of Braun
in the variety of ways that the country
has through every sector every
institution every media company every
general business major corporations the
military every part of American society
has internalized the need to work on
integration and to overcome the past so
there's still work to be done
universities across the country continue
to try to do their part but we are
gradually I'm afraid losing a battle on
this the opponents of affirmative action
have this new technique of amending
state constitutions when this is not
framed in a normal kind of public debate
but just on a ballot that says should
there be preferential treatment based on
race the way that's framed the average
person may say no it doesn't sound right
when in fact if discussed in a more
robust and fulsome way people would
would accept a different outcome so we
have this new method there's been quite
successful unfortunately we also have a
time limit that the Supreme Court in
Gruder put on affirmative action 25
years we're only 14 years away from that
not clear what will happen at that point
but we also have opponents of
affirmative action who are going to
continue actively bringing litigation
against universities and
I'm worried about General Counsel's
becoming too cautious and advising
universities about this most importantly
I think we've lost as a society or are
losing the ability to talk about this in
a way that is gives rise to a full
understanding of what we're facing the
theme about the real problem being
inequality of income and wealth and that
you should focus more on that and if you
do you will also have greater diverse
racial and ethnic diversity and
therefore you won't have to take race
and ethnicity into account consciously
in order to address these issues I think
it's it's both faults on the solution
and and really misses the point on the
on the first because of course we're
concerned with inequality of wealth and
income of course we want to maintain
access from all parts of the society of
course it's a basic principle in
American life that your child's
education should not depend upon the
wealth of the family we should work on
that we do work on that but where its
faults on the on the solution is that
all the scholarship that exists on this
points out what is a sort of undeniable
fact that the effort to try to achieve
greater access for low-income children
from low-income backgrounds will not
really yield racial and ethnic diversity
and that's because of demographics that
in every sector of American life the
largest population is going to be white
and therefore by focusing only on a
particular aspect of the race or
ethnicity you will end up with less
racial and ethnic diversity
afterwards we only admit qualified
students these are students who come
from the very highest sector performance
on standardized tests and grade point
averages we consider lots of factors in
deciding whether to admit people the
classes that are composed
clearly everybody virtually everybody
really likes a diverse student body they
thrive on it they applaud it when you
say at commencement speeches one of the
great things about this is you've had a
diverse class experience yes students
saying
so when pal said in Bakke that you can
only talk about educational benefits
from diversity and not because of the
past and the need to do something now to
remedy that universities took that as a
order basically a caution not to talk
about the historical context and how
that plays into the present in the need
for addressing what is effectively still
a divided society and so we speak too
often in this vague highly general
almost banal way of about diversity
because we're afraid given where the
Supreme Court has defined the purpose
that's acceptable under the Constitution
we're afraid that we will cross that
line and our policies will be held
unconstitutional
that's very very unfortunate because it
leaves a very important voice in the
society that is higher education
essentially out of the picture when it's
talking about why it does what it does
and then coupled with that is I'm afraid
a kind of timidity within the political
culture not to really address this and I
think most politicians find a dangerous
to really come out on these issues and
say that they support affirmative action
or diversity except in a very general
way so while the reality of a continuing
segregation almost a return of
segregation since Brown Plus problems of
racism that still persist in the society
and a general feeling that there's work
to be done you have the reality and then
you have the absence of a robust public
debate about this and discussion about
what to do so 60 years after Brown we're
facing a situation which we can be quite
proud as a nation of what's been
accomplished it's a different world from
what it was before and yet there's an
enormous amount to be done and we are
sliding back in certain ways and we're
not discussing it in a way
that I think will be most productive in
keeping alive the spirit of brown
you